hello everybody my name is markiplier
with his coworkers yeah welcome back to
let's play this Stan how terrible is the
memo
wait what ok nevermind I thought I saw
something different but apparently I did
not okay so what I need to do is I need
to get back to that room as quickly as I
can't of to open doors he entered the
door Neil and I keep seeing things that
I think are different but they're not
necessarily very different so yet there
was not a single person here either and
feeling a wave of disbelief and they
decided to go up to his boss's office
coming to a staircase Stanley walked
upstairs to his boss's office I wonder
if there's another code somewhere hidden
in the game that you could put in
there's two eight four five I know that
stealing ranked or manager's office
Stanley was once again stunned to
discover not an indication of any human
shadows was in such a rush to get
through the story as quickly as possible
he didn't even have a single minute to
just let the narrator talk that kind of
anxiety isn't healthy though he relaxed
for a few moments Oh with some calming
new-age music
oh yeah oh that's the stuff I feel so
relaxed ah ah you know there's this
video on YouTube of me of someone who
collected sound by feelings ooh that's
going to entail Stanley calmly walked
forward into the opened passageway
uh-huh well thank you for that anyway
this is collection a sound might to be
going after like scares you ha got it ah
ah it's just combination me like ahh ooh
ahh ooh ahh f me ah so it's like you
know that um anyway that's uh so anyway
back to the Stanley parable I know
everyone are you're all clicking away
from this video to try to find that
League
markiplier sexy noises you know a lot of
people make like that fanfiction stuff
and fan art about me and and I see it
you know I find it I Honey walk straight
ahead switch used to ignore it read mind
control facility wait a minute is your
another choice here I really wonder what
would happen if I let myself die in that
I don't know but I need to do something
else here I need to use the machine for
power rose on an enormous room packed
with television yeah what horrible
secret to this place hope Oh horrible so
we have the strength to find out yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah whatever old hat at
this point I got a nice debate jump to
life their true nature revealed huh each
bore the number of an employee in the
building understand is coworkers there's
no gaps of so many individuals reduced
to images on a screen
and Stanley one of them eternally wanted
to his ease with freedom meant nothing
where freedom meant nothing I need to
find out what number that is
lippy flippy flippy flippy flippy flippy
flippy flippy oh come on flippy damn it
maybe you'd only aah five to eight I'm
gonna remember that five to eight five
two eight five two eight Flair Mookie
now a mind control facility it was too
horrible to believe that could be true
oh yes Danny really been under someone's
control all this time yes any reason he
was happy with his boring job that his
emotions had been manipulated to accept
it blindly probably at this point I
believed everything he refused to
believe it he couldn't accept it her own
life in someone else's control who never
it was unthinkable wasn't it was it even
possible had he truly spent his entire
life utterly blind to the world who
knows he sings me and was the proof the
heart of the operation controls labeled
with emotions happy or sad or content
walking eating working all of it
monitored and commanded from this very
place and as the cold reality of his
past began to sink in Stanley decided
that this machinery would never again
exert its terrible power over another
human life if you say so men would
dismantle the controls once and for all
okay let's try this again but I'm gonna
turn the power on live on you ready for
this y'all ready for this system power
Oh Oh Stanley you didn't just activate
the controls did you yep after they kept
you enslaved all these years you go and
you try to take control of the
for your selfies yeah what you want is
control yes Stanley help Lord or ever
die really do but you need to understand
there's only so much that machine can do
you were supposed to let it go nope turn
the controls off and be know if you want
to throw my story of track you're gonna
have to do much better than that okay
I'm afraid you don't have nearly the
power you think you do for example and I
believe you'll find this person n't
Stanley suddenly realized he had just
initiated the network's emergency
detonation sting I remember this end
that this machine is activated without
proper DNA identification nuclear
detonators are set to explode ah
eliminating the entire complex
how long until detonation
let's say two minutes two minutes this
is making things a little more fun isn't
it Stanley no your time to shine you are
the star it's your story now shape it to
his eyes where's number three better
than what I had him before is a fair so
little time left to enjoy it shall our
moments until the bomb goes off
but what perhaps yes each one of them
years I need press number one I am to
talk about you okay pop me where we're
going
whiner this means I barely move started
I bred one one you're glad to know where
your co-workers are a moment of Solace
before you're obliterated oh all right
I'm in a good mood you're gonna die
anyway I'll tell you exactly what
happened to them crap
I raised them green of the machine I set
you free queen of course that was merely
an instance of the story sometimes when
I tell it I simply let you see there in
your office forever pushing buttons
endlessly and then dying alone three
times I let the office sink into the
ground swallowing everyone inside oh
then - ah I had to say this though this
version of events has been rather room
what do I do when you try to make sense
of everything and take back the control
rested away from yours quite rich assed
hate to see it go and I'm sure whatever
I come up with on the next go-around
I'll be even better my goodness only 34
seconds less shut up but I'm enjoying
this so much you know what deal with it
I'm going to put some extra
on the clock oh thank you these are
precious additional what do I do this is
exactly the problem I had before Oh dear
me
what's the matter Stanley is it that you
have no idea where you're going or what
you're supposed to be doing right now
huh or did you just assume when you saw
that timer that something in this room
was capable of turning it off I mean
look at you running from button button
screen to screen clicking on every
little thing in this room numbered
buttons no these colored ones or maybe
this big red button all this door
everything anything something here will
save me ah stairs number three okay
video game can be beaten hang on wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait do you
have any idea what your purpose in this
place is you understand me you're in for
quite a disappointment but here's a
spoiler freedom three a timer isn't a
catalyst to keep the action moving the
wall
it's just seconds ticking away too
shut up and he's still playing instead
of watching a cutscene because I want to
watch you for every moment that you're
powerless shall I see you made humble
shut up this is not a challenge it's a
tragedy
shut up wanted to control this world
that's fine I'm going to destroy it
first
Salim Khan shut up the guard at the
clock stand that's 30 seconds you have
left
thirty seconds until the peak now I
press and knowing Oh be blowed Oh God
will you clean desperately to your frail
life little ESPYs another choice make it
cut order it's all the same to me all a
part of the joke and believe me I will
be laughing at every second of your
inevitable life from the moment we fade
in until the moment I say happy ever
ah ah maybe there is no way no there's
got to be a way to do that I'm gonna
find out the way I'm gonna find it out
dammit alright so I'm back now and I
actually played through the entire mind
control spammy button thingy again and
uh there was some slightly different
dialogue but it wasn't anything
significant so I'm gonna try to find
something else because I really really
perhaps he wanted to stop by the
employee of God I've got an idea
I've got an idea of what I want to do
Wow yes this room what a beautiful room
Wow gorgeous but eager to get back to
business whatever I don't care about
that rooms open door on his left
yeah whatever no but how would happen if
I know
no bad at following directions
uncredible he wasn't fine here's a shut
up what happens if I what happens if I I
think
but now Guinness to prove that he is in
control no one gets to tell him what to
do
sternly left from the platform and
plunged to his death
a good job Stanley everyone thinks you
are very powerful hey God dang dingus oh
hang on wait everybody wait no Stanley
thought to himself am I sure that the
orders stopped coming in how is that
possible they never stopped surely I was
mistaken
hmm we would it no no the orders were
still missing
for now for now does that mean
who do I wear on his back
yeah the orders aren't back okay I'm
gonna keep doing what I was gonna do oh
yeah nothing to say now oh you just
total silence man hey is gonna when
Stanley came to a set of two open doors
if this was not the correct way to the
mission
sure I knew it perfectly well no perhaps
he wanted to stop by the employee lounge
first just to admire it maybe the lounge
was sublime
a work of art yeah whatever but eager to
get back to business damn it if you're
here open door on his left no god damn
it was so bad at following directions
it's incredible he wasn't five years ago
got an idea
look Stanley I think perhaps we've
gotten off on the wrong foot nope I'm
not your head no nope I realize that
invested in your trust in someone else
can be difficult no but the fact is that
the story has been about nothing but you
all this time
yeah this what really I was in the
middle of something do you have zero
consideration for others are you that
convinced that I want something bad to
happen to you yep what I don't know how
to convince you of this but I really do
want to help you no you're not beautiful
no let me prove it let me prove that I'm
on your side oh okay
oh listen carefully this is important Oh
Stanley walked through the red door oh
okay I walked through the red door oh
thank God you are willing to listen to
me yes you see that I really have wanted
you to be happy all this yeah the
problem is all these choices the two of
us always trying to get somewhere that
isn't here yawning and running and
running just the way you're doing right
now
yeah don't you see that it's killing us
Stanley would killing me I wanted to
stop I would we would both be so much
happier if we just
stopped and I think well I think I have
a solution here let me show you okay all
right wait a minute
what weird one do I go through G job huh
hmm what do we want what are we looking
for
why you being so weird narrator I mean
you're weird normally but why are you
being so whoa oh it's beautiful if we
just stay right here right in this
moment with this place stamp I think I
feel me
I actually feel happy okay well what
about that why do I care
oh wait I don't all right I'm leaving go
back go back
wait what whoa pretty collars man they
kind of do feel happy but what cuz it's
stopping whoa that is pretty trippy man
and I fall off no I can't
all right gotta go bye no wait where are
you going
what why uh-oh
it's degrading back into the office Oh
No
stay away from those stairs if you hurt
yourself if you die the game will reset
we'll lose all of this yeah will we stay
yeah you didn't feel that way when you
were blowing me up with a nuclear mom
let me stay here don't take this from me
oh oh oh wait a minute
uh wait a minute that wait a minute
please Stanley think about what you're
doing I I'm thinking about it I'm
thinking about it
thought about it ow oh thank god yeah
you lived huh you have me worried there
for a moment huh now can we please get
back to the other room no no no no what
are you doing standing back please I
asked annual to take this away from me
I can't go back to what I was before if
you die we'll both go back why are you
doing this why not well why shouldn't I
give me one good reason come on just one
one good reason no I know all right
ow Stanley let's go back to the other
room No can you do that my car is this
really how much you dislike my game ah
throw yourself from this platform over
and over to be rid of it literally
willing to kill yourself to keep me from
being happy yeah my reading the
situation correctly yep because you're a
son of a hey maybe you're just
getting a kick out of it oh I don't know
anymore I just wanted us to get along no
but I guess that was too much to ask my
happiness is not in that Rhonda to make
a choice after all well this one is
yours you got it right here we go
it's going to restart isn't it I'm going
back yeah whoa
what the well this is an adventure I
will adventure in in the next episode I
guess oh yeah wait oh I should do my
outro shouldn't I uh-huh thank you all
so much for watching clicked in baseball
babe
bud
portal